taye nous avons cinq rédactions
avec nous nous allons commencer par les
questions permettez moi de donner la
parole mais j'ai donné au king's le
représentant de la rédaction américaine
oui bonjour messieurs lavrov bonjour
madame zakharova je me réjouis d'être
avec vous en ligne c'est très agréable
de discuter avec vous que ce soit en
ligne que ce soit en présentiel je
voudrais commencer notre discussion par
les questions suivantes les etats unis
continuent à ignorer les propositions de
la russie quant aux mécanismes de la
sécurité collective et les demandes de
ne pas franchir la ligne rouge posée par
moscou cela concerne notamment
l'élargissement de l'otan vers l'est
alors deux questions en ce sens
à quoi est lié cette silence est ce que
la russie peut le tolérer mais cet
occident collectif est ce qu'il est
capable
d'accepter les propositions russes quant
à la coexistence pacifique merci benoît
sibaud oui merci
je pense que c'est une question
d'actualité
mais je ne dirais pas que nos
initiatives sont ignorés
c'est le président poutine qui en a
parlé lors du collège énergie du
ministre de la défense ministère de la
défense et je veux mentionner que
pendant la visioconférence avec le
président hayden ils ont traité de ce
sujet le précédent john se dit prêt 2
d'envisager les préoccupations de la
partie russe et nous avons présenté
notre vision de ces accords possibles en
documents concernent les relations entre
la russie et les etats unis
se dit comment s'appelle accord sur les
questions sécuritaires entre la
fédération de russie et les etats-unis
et le deuxième document le projet de
l'accord
pour régler les problèmes de la sécurité
dans le cadre des relations russie otan
ce match malgré le fait que monsieur
stoltenberg
le directeur général de l'alliance a
constamment fait des déclarations non
adéquat
il va démissionner presta sa démission à
la fin de l'année et des bruits
circulent qui va travailler dans la
banque centrale de norvège où tu t'es
laissé volonté mais dans la banque
centrale le tour il faut
respecter tout ce qui est à la base du
fonctionnement de telle ou tel
établissement alors en ce qui concerne
la sécurité européenne et euro
atlantique il y ajoute une base des
principes qui ont été agréées et qui ont
été signés au plus haut niveau en tant
que engagement politique obligation
politique
c'est le principe de la sécurité
égale et non divisible
et
aucun état dans cette région aucun porte
participants ne devra pas à renforcer sa
sécurité au détriment de la sécurité des
autres pays et quand monsieur stenberg
dit de manière arrogante
même
hypocrite que personne n'a le droit de
frôler 2
de violer cette déclaration de
washington sans lesquels tout le monde
peut adhérer
à l'organisation
de cette organisation le temps je peux
dire que nous ne faisons pas partie de
cette structure nous ne sont pas le pays
signataires mais nous sommes les
signataires à des
deux documents plus large heureux de
l'antique dans lesquels on parle des
principes de la non dits visibilité de
la sécurité et si monsieur c'est une
dépense
qu'on peut ignorer cela ce cas était
ancré dans le document du haut niveau
donc je pense que monsieur stone d'arc
peut présenter sa démission choisir en
entrant pas parce que pour l'instant il
ne respecte pas ses propres obligations
en ce qui concerne la réaction réelle et
non pas rhétorique que je viens de
mentionner je dirais la chose suivante
c'est plutôt une position d'affaires du
point de vue de la part de nos collègues
américains il y a eu des discussions
entre les aides
de des présidents et suite à en contact
régulier des modalités d'organisation et
est agréé
au début de l'année suivante
il y aura la première étape ce sera le
contact bilatéral entre nos négociateurs
et les négociateurs américains les noms
ont été déjà donné
c'est acceptable pour les deux parties
et après cela nous envisageons au moins
de janvier
aussi d'utiliser une autre plateforme de
négociation pour décider du deuxième
document le projet d'accord entre la
russie et les pays de l'otan
le président s'est entretenu avec le
président m'a cran avec la chance champ
solaire chancelier monsieur olaf scholz
ils sont également intéressés par ce
sujet notre président a réaffirmé que
cette question des garanties de sécurité
serait portée
sur la plateforme de le laisser en
europe bref
il ya cette question qu'il faut
l'appliquer mais en tout cas il ya un
accord entre moscou et washington et je
ne vois pas que kylie a et qu'il y ait
une contradiction entre notre position
est la position d'autres
bien sûr
il ya les tiens et si quelque chose se
passe les américains nous ont dit que il
y a des préoccupations de notre part qui
ont démarré dans le document ils le
peuvent les discuter puis il ya ceux qui
ne peuvent pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas
envisager et puis il ya leurs propres
préoccupations mais ils ne les ont pas
encore présenté
alors nous allons comprendre
ce qui se passe du point de vue de
l'organisation
en ce qui concerne le continue il faut
procéder au travail mais ce travail ne
pas être sans limites parce qu'il ya
toujours une menace
depuis des dizaines d'années à titre
permanent et l'infrastructure militaire
de l'otan s'approchent d'eux près de nos
frontières
on nous a trompés de manière régulière
en commençant par les déclarations
orales et en terminant par les
obligations politiques qui ont été mis
sur le papier dans l'acte fondateur a
réussi autant
cette fois ci comme l'a dit le président
poutine nous insistons sur ces garanties
contraignantes juridique
et en même temps nos cours il faut
comprendre que
le temps que l'occident peut violer
c'est garanti même écrite et sortir de
ces garanties comme c'était par exemple
concernant les
le traité chez lui vers le traité fini
le traité abm
mais
les
les obligations juridiques c'est plus
facile de les violer
c'est plus difficile par rapport à
l'obligation morale de toute façon nous
sommes prêtes à prêts à travailler nous
sommes ouverts et nous ferons tout pour
qu'on nous comprenne
et j'espère que grâce pas que nous
entreprenons pour assurer notre sécurité
j'espère qu'on va nous prendre au
sérieux
nous passons à la deuxième question la
rédaction allemande
oman ziskin
nous recevons des nouvelles de votre
front on peut dire que c'est vraiment
presque en francs militaire parce qu'il
ya beaucoup d'obstacles dans votre
travail
s'il vous plaît votre commentaire votre
question bonjour monsieur lavrov bonjour
madame accords vins quand vous savez
erté a finalement lancé la chaîne en
helmand mais une semaine ni pas déjà n'a
pas d'âge a écoulé
quand la chaîne a été coupé par
satellite grâce date 9 b on ne menace
par les cours par la fermeture youtube a
supprimé donc
notre chaîne est ce que le ministère
russe des affaires étrangères est au
courant de cette situation et est ce que
vous envisagez de prendre des pas
concrets pour soutenir la chaîne et des
journalistes russes oui nous sommes au
courant maya zakharova la commande est
déjà plusieurs reprises nous suivons de
près
tout ce qui se
passe comment nos journalistes et
travaillent à l'étranger
ce compte tenu de ces faits de
discrimination
par exemple rt n'a pas d'accréditation
ce politique n'a pas des crédits tation
auprès de l'elysée
le président poutine lors de sa
conversation téléphonique avec monsieur
macron à attirer l'attention sur ce fait
il a exprimé son n'espère son espoir que
nos collègues français et fassent tout
pour que les médias russes y compris rt
travail en france et que leur travail
soit aussi confortable que le travail de
leurs homologues de leurs collègues en
russie
et ce principe nous devrions l'appliquer
a hérité en allemagne et autres masses
médias russes qui sont confrontés à ces
discriminations à l'étranger
en ce qui concerne l allemagne c temps
car sinon sans précédent les autorités
et je tiens à le souligner il y avait
les tentatives de diviser
leurs activités des activités des
régulateurs ils ont fait tout pour créer
une image négative de votre chaîne dans
la société allemand allemande et parmi
les structures allemandes vous savez
bien ils ont commencé par bloquer les
services bancaires puis ils ont refusé
d'enregistrer la chaîne puis ils ont
refusé luxembourg de le faire mais
maintenant nos collègues en serbie ont
enregistré votre chaîne en langue
allemande et
en vertu de la convention de
la division et de la diffusion il faut
le respecter
les réseaux sociaux youtube on dit que
c'est leur propre initiative qu'ils ont
leurs propres critères et les autorités
allemandes ne sont pour rien mais ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas vrai
parce que toutes les obligations
de liberté de l'information
ce sont les autorités qui ont signé ces
obligations ce n'était pas youtube ou
autre service qui qui l'ont fait
les le gouvernement sur la teneur du
quai ça se passe il est responsable de
cette libre arbitre nous avons déjà dit
à plusieurs reprises que cette
discrimination se poursuivait depuis
déjà des années et des années
et bien sûr trop souvent il y avait
cette tentative de prendre les mesures
de représailles
mais
jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
nous avons eu cette conviction
que nous ne voulons pas envisager le
même scénario
la section des des mass médias comme le
font nos partenaires occidentaux
mais vous savez c'est la même chose avec
la sécurité de la fédération de russie
il ya des limites pour notre patience et
je ne peux pas exclure ce scénario que
si cette situation continue nous allons
prendre des mesures de représailles
marie est arras tina et rédaction
espagnol s'il vous plaît à vous la
parole bonjour madame zakharova monsieur
lavrov la question concernant notre
région de l'amérique latine il y a eu
toute une série d'événements importants
par exemple les élections au chili où
les représentants des forces de gauche à
eu la victoire devrait d'après le mot
reach il en est de même pour les
élections au honduras il y a le
venezuela le nicaragua mais quand même
les états unis continuent à envisager
cette région comme sa zone d'intérêt
quand ainsi vous est ce que le
changement de cap politique dans ces
pays lundi ce que l'amérique latine
devient de plus en plus indépendantes du
point de vue politique ou cette région
du point de vue des américains elle
reste leur propre région reste leur
ventre mou si je puis dire et ils
devront s'aligner sur les règles
imposées par les états unis par exemple
dans l'esprit du sommet de la démocratie
qui s'est tenue récemment
ces derniers 50 ans 60 ans voire plus
a subi des transformations
politiques
il y avait des tendances de gauche de
droite
maintenant il y à une nouvelle vague
quand il y a des des forces nationales
et scène qui viennent le pouvoir et je
pense que c'est cela témoigne du fait
que le projet néolibéral a essuyé en
échec cuisant
mais dans nos relations
jamais là la fédération de russie n'a
pas construit c'est
son cap sa politique est selon
le fait qu'ils se trouvent au pouvoir
nous voudrions établir des relations
avec tout et
nous ne nous référons pas aux
préférences politiques oui à la
différence des états unis et nous
n'envisageons pas cette région pour
comme en terrain pour les jeux
géopolitiques
l'administration courante des états unis
a
répété
les déclarations de john bolton que la
doctrine monroe elle reste vivante
mais je pense que cette mentalité
cette mentalité reste toujours en place
même si ils ont dit le contraire
nous en ce qui nous concerne nous
travaille avec tous les pays avec les
régions sous régionale
dans la région de l'amérique latine et
des caraïbes
j'ai eu des contacts ces dernières
années avec mes collègues du mexique du
venezuela du muliplient de la bolivie du
brésil du guatemala du nicaragua du
honduras
de kouba du belize à new york lors de la
session de l'assemblée générale j'ai
rencontré les représentants de
cette région avec mes collègues
d'argentine j'ai aussi eu des contacts
dans le cadre du groupe des vingt nous
soulignons toujours nous sommes
intéressés à avoir une coopération
dépolitiser ce qui concerne les
relations bilatérales à ce qui concerne
les structures
multilatérale les organisations
internationales bien sûr
comme la plupart des pays de l'amérique
latine nous défendons les valeurs les
normes les objectifs de la charte des
nations unies d'ailleurs l'année
dernière à l'initiative du venezuela en
groupe a été créé le groupe des amis de
la défense de la charte et ce groupe
comprend déjà plus de 20 participants je
pense que les pays de l'amérique latine
vont rejoindre ce mécanisme
ce mécanisme répond aux tentatives des
états unis et de ses alliés les plus
proches
d'eux s'éloigner du droit international
et de ceux basés dans leurs déclarations
dans leurs arguments dans leurs
politiques sur
le l'ordre basé sur les règles qu'ils
ont inventé heumann
ce sont les règles qui est élaboré par
leur propre groupe restreint il n'y a
pas dans ce cercle d'opinion alternative
il n'y a pas de discussion bref la
vérité neuner ce n'est pas dans dans ces
circonstances
je vois que les états unis
l'administration du président
aborde une approche plus pragmatique de
ce qui se passe
notamment il me semble qu'il
envisage de prendre d'autres actions à
l'encontre du venezuela ils comprennent
qu'il faudra mener un dialogue avec le
gouvernement monsieur m'a d'euros qui
après les élections à reconfirmer son
mandat la situation analogique et en
bolivie
où la démocratie
véritable a été établi après les actions
douteuses des
des dirigeants précédents
et cetera et ainsi de suite
j'espère qu'au nicaragua
ce serait la même chose
de toute façon nous sommes pour que
on contribue à la formation en amérique
latine de l'identité latine de l'aide
d'un kit et des caraïbes et ce serait en
pole du monde de l'ordre qui est en
train de se former et en ce sens
nous apprécions nos relations avec les
structures régionales et sous régionales
dans cette région notamment avec la
communauté des débits latine et des
caraïbes
avec eux nous avons des mécanismes des
consultations politiques
il y avait une pause due à la pandémie
commis 19 les mexicains sont à présent
les présidents de cette organisation et
nous sommes pour renouveler les contacts
nous allons soutenir cette position
ce qui concerne d'autres volets de notre
coopération je vais mentionner les
hautes technologies l'énergie ainsi que
l'agriculture bien évidemment l'espace
l'énergie nucléaire et ces dernières
années c'était la médecine la santé
publique et certains pays de l'amérique
latine le mexique et le brésil
l'argentine le nayrac aragua
ont déjà reçu les technologies de la
production de nos vaccins
il
travaille avec cette technologie est il
un star maintenant la production donc je
pense que nos contacts et suivantes
donneront
un nouvel élan pour la coopération plus
générale en matière d production
pharmaceutique la santé et la médecine
aujourd'hui la rédaction arabe est
présenté par maximale de riz c'est à
vous la parole s'il vous plaît merci
madame zakharova bonjour à tous bonjour
monsieur le ministre
bien sûr nous avons pas mal de questions
ce qui est d'intérêt pour un autre
bourne spectateurs pendant auditeurs
nous mais nous n'avons pas beaucoup de
temps pour poser toutes les questions
j'ai une question relative à léran
l'occident accuse toujours les rangs
dans l'escaladé nucléaire continue ce
qu'est à lui revu peut mener à la
défiance des pourparlers sur le gcp
tandis que téhéran continue de dire que
c'est plutôt la campagne de
désinformation de la part de l'occident
au lieu des pourparlers sérieux quelle
est la position de la russie et qu'est
ce qui requiert pour le succès de ces
pourparlers
malheureusement pour moi nous pour par
les occidentaux cherchent à dénaturer
les faits
pendant la première question qu'on m'a
posée
le temps aussi
s'approche d'une manière exponentielle
de frontières
c'est la même histoire ici avec
vous les rangs l'administration
américaine d'être un peu
et sorties de tous les accords du cepeo
et du de la résolution du conseil de
sécurité
mais c'est toujours les rangs qui est
responsable
après c'est ce geste de trempe les
iraniens pendant une année n'ont rien
fait ce qui va à l'encontre de leurs
obligations
suite à le suite je cp et
uniquement au moment où la sortie
américaine était inévitable les rangs
enfants a pris des gestes en ce qui
concerne les obligations prises
d'une manière volontaire par les
iraniens le concerne les garanties pour
le volontaire qui était toujours
respecté
cela concerne l'arrêt schisme en uranium
où le lancement des centrifugeuses plus
moderne mais ils disent qu une fois les
américaines reviennent au respect de
leurs obligations les iraniens vont
suivre c'est notamment ce principe cette
vision qui forment la base et des
pourparlers à vienne
[Musique]
entre avril et juin six tours des
pourparlers
les iraniennes les aimerait qu'elle ne
se sont pas mises ensemble sur la table
de négociation c'était le groupe des
coordinateurs qui a travaillé les
représentants du
du service de la politique
internationale de l'union européenne la
france et l'allemagne mais à l'issue de
sites ouvrent des pauvres parlé en
disant on a créé
la vision sur le futur qui dans l'espoir
à des des mesures à suivre dès des
objectifs des résultats plutôt positifs
ensuite ne partenaires occidentaux
ont manifesté de l'intolérance
mais en fait il faut pas oublier que
c'est l'iran qui a attendu pendant un
nom que les amériques et reviennent vers
le deal joue donc je dirais que les
actes iraniens sont naturels
je voudrais éviter toute dramatisation
évidemment en maintenant les autorités
iraniennes sont
nouvelles mais je dirais que c'est trop
vite qu'ils se sont renseignés sur la
situation présente ma fin de compte ils
ont reconnu que les propositions sont
légitimes on peut étudier les nouvelles
propositions et c'est dans cette
direction qu'on bouge maintenant
je dirais que les problèmes qui ont
surgi n'était pas due
mou du contenu de la substance mais
plutôt du
de la nature technique et
les rangs croyait que le premier pas
doit être réalisée par les américains
parce que c'était eux qui ont décidé de
sortir du jcp les américains contraire
ont
insisté que c'était et l'iran qui avait
violé ses obligations et ses les rangs
qui devait agir le premier avec nos amis
chinois avec les iraniens
nous avons
défendu la synchronisation des actes
pour avoir un paquet de mesures
conjointes
les négociateurs à vienne ont pris une
petite pause dans leurs actes pour
célébrer le noël mais d'ici à la fin de
l'année les pourparlers vont reprendre
et iran confirme encore une fois que si
les américains reviennent vers le
respect de leurs obligations si les
américains
arrête de menacer les les sanctions qui
va à l'encontre de la résolution
de 31 à l'iran respecté le protocole
additionnel
en garantie intégrale à de lei a donc à
mon avis nous avons belle chance de
dabou tirs il faut aussi prendre en
compte que le principe
qui est pertinent c'est que rien n'est
négocié avant que tout ne soit négocié
je voudrais vous rappeler que nous
sommes en direct avec le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe monsieur
lavrov avec la chaîne rt nous sommes en
direct
dans toutes les langues du
la chaîne arte
maintenant c'est le tour de la rédaction
française c'est à vous la parole
merci beaucoup madame makarova bonjour
monsieur lavrov j'ai une question
relative à la déclaration du mr
étrangers français jean yves le drian
vous avez dit qu'il a averti la russie
sur les conséquences extrêmement graves
dans le cas d'une intervention sur le
territoire ukrainien votre avis pourquoi
est ce que les communications avec les
occidentaux ont pris la forme des
menaces en définit je crois que c'est la
question posée à eux plus tôt pour moi
c'est pas une source de plaisir
mais c'est pas une source des mesures
négatives non plus parce que nous sommes
habitués à avoir des conversations avec
les oxydants de là où il cherche à nous
imposer quelque chose à nous donner la
leçon
ils se considèrent les maîtres des
surhumains qui
qui n'ont pas pêché dans leur politique
les autorités françaises à plusieurs
reprises ont déclaré qu'ils vont
demander quelque chose de nous voici
leur demande
mais à mon avis le président russe
pendant ces dernières semaines c'est que
d'autres représentants des autorités
russes ont abordé plusieurs fois le
sujet de soi disant escalade pour
laquelle on ne menace de punir
on a déjà même préparé un paquet de
sanctions si je ne me trompe pas
dans les média social aujourd'hui on
peut parler d'acheter quelque chose d'
avance donc selam un paquet de sanctions
d'avant ce qui avait déjà été préparée
mais de notre côté nous avons déjà donné
des explications sur les actions de nos
forces armées ce qu'elles font sur notre
propre territoire c'est la même histoire
avec les français les britanniques
les actes de leurs véhicules de leurs
forces armées
c'est leurs actes à la frontière russe
dans les pays baltes les navires de
combat sur la mer là ils viol aussi des
la convention de montreux par exemple
nous leur posons des questions mais un
réponse nous n'entendons rien
sauf les menaces
permanentes à mon avis au lieu de menace
nos partenaires occidentaux ferait mieux
de se concentrer sur leurs obligations
direct la france et l'allemagne doivent
faire qui est vert respecter les accords
de minsk a au lieu de
te faire des déviations
en accusant la russie de
d'une désescalade une escalade
une annexion dedans basse d'une part
d'un pass ou de l'ukraine
entière
soutien
zelensky et sans régime
parle toujours de la crimée ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya deux ans parce
qu'à cette époque là on a eu l'espoir
que kiev pourrait respecter les accords
de minsk ceux qui étaient ses promesses
a lors de sa campagne électorale
mais une fois le président et l'a
compris que soit il ne pourra pas le
faire soit elle ne veut pas le faire
soit elle sera
bloquée par les néo-nazis et c est donc
pour
[Musique]
ne pas se faire voir comme un puissant
il s'est mis à parler d'eux
de la crimée ce que devenue le symbole
de la politique internationale craignent
n 10 il l'émergence de cette plateforme
de la crimée je crois que tout le monde
le comprend et compris nos collègues
occidentaux qui joue dans ce jeu mais
quant aux obligations sérieuse
sans aucun jeu c'est de faire héliski
respecter les résolutions du conseil de
sécurité qui a confir confirmé à
l'existence des accords de misc et là
c'est l'ordre des mesures à prendre par
l'ukraine si il s'agit de la mystique du
statut spécial
de l'organisation des élections
aux conditions a grillé avec le
le dombass sous l'égide de la ce et
uniquement après on peut pas si on peut
procéder à la restauration du contrôle
des forces armées craignait le long de
la frontière pour l'instant on entend
les propositions contraires
est-ce qu'on va entendre encore une fois
sur les statuts spéciaux on ne le sait
pas mais c'était l'objet des discussions
entre le président russe et le président
français le chancelier should il s'agit
aussi ne la loi d'une période de
transition qui était
soumise à la rada suprême
mais si c'est tout loi est adoptée
le parlement ne pourrait respecter les
accords de minsk on entend plutôt de
lustration des citoyens
on parle uniquement du contrôle
restaurer
sur les territoires en excès et malgré
les promesses à allemand des promesses
de ne pas de faire ne pas adopter cette
loi n'est moi cette loi est poussé
avancé dans le cadre normatif et même la
commission
de venise
a dit qu'il n'y a pas de problème avec
cette loi
rien n'est dit que cela va à l'encontre
de la résolution du conseil de sécurité
onusien donc j'ai eu une demande
mon un ami jean yves le drian et à mes
collègues allemands je veux madame le
broc à la marge du conseil de le sud
qu'elle a aussi manifesté son intérêt
dans le respect des accords de misc donc
c'est un bon moment pour
faire respecter ces accords du ministre
probablement ainsi pourrait-on oubliés
du ses applications
non naturelle daniel donc les rédactions
anglophone je voudrais continuer avec
l'agent dac commencer par un ma collègue
française les médias occidentaux
continuent de parler de la crise
craignant sinon depuis longtemps parlé
des milliers de soldats russes à la
frontière ukrainienne à plusieurs
reprises vous avez
dit que cette sorte de compagnie
représentent une opération spéciale dans
ce contexte la russie a fait a pris une
mesure sans précédent et 10 voile et les
communications avec la france et
l'allemagne l'objectif
étant d'éviter la position des natures
et de la russie donc est ce que
l'objectif avait été atteint
je suis convaincu
que
c'était une bonne idée de le faire
je ne veux pas
appelé au bon sens de qui que ce soit
je dirais que dans la diplomatie il faut
abandonner les émotions
et mon collègue a dit qu'il faut avoir
le
bon sang ce cynique
et de ce point de vue je crois que si
vous regardez ses communications vous
allez voir
que les accusations ne sont pas
justifiées qui disent que la russie
créer des obstacles pour les pourparlers
dans le format normandie ne sont
vraiment préoccupé par le fait que les
accords de mise que sont dénaturés par
les applis de kiev
je les répéter je le répète parce que je
lui ai dit en répondant à la question
précédente mais les français les
allemands comme les co auteurs de ce
document comme les membres du forum en
normandie
prennent
le parti du régime craignant
auparavant ils ont dit qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative aux accords de mise qu'il
faut les respecter en totalité mais
maintenant je ne me souviens plus d'une
date si je ne me trompe pas c'était le
12 octobre lors du sommet
de l'ukraine et l'union européenne
est lourde ce sommet on a entendu la
déclaration que la russie doit faire ça
et ça mais qui est va bien fait en
respectant ses obligations
dans le groupe de contact au sein du
groupe de contact est
du format normandie
le président résume ce qui vient de
s'entretenir avec les dirigeants
français et allemands est là aussi lors
de ce chat mais on a entendu un soutien
complet des actions de kiev l'ubo
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
donc soit nos collègues confirme à leur
incapacité
d'assurer le respect des accords de myst
soit au contraire ils ont pris le cap de
torpiller ces accords de minsk
pour plaire au régime ukrainien
je ne peux pas vous dire quelles seront
les conséquences
bien sûr nous allons faire de notre
mieux pour avoir le respect
gide de ces documents parce que c'est
écrit noir sur blanc tout d'abord cessez
le feu ensuite le retrait des véhicules
ensuite la restauration des rapports
économiques ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
l'instant mais même plus on voit
toujours là bloqua de
siéger dès the blast de lougansk de
donetsk
et les
les résidents de ces territoires se
battent pour leur survie
nous leur donnons des passeports pour
qu'il puisse travailler sur le marché de
travail russes pour qu'ils puissent
avoir des revenus mais dans cette
situation on nous accuse de torpiller
les accords de misc la même situation
avec les citoyennetés les polonais les
en croit les romanais
et dont des passeports à leurs
compatriotes c'était l'histoire pendant
des décennies ce n'était pas la cause
des divergences
mais pour l'instant on voit parler des
radicaux ukrainien avec le soutien des
occidentaux
bien sûr c
c'est déplorable et j'espère
à propos
en juin lors du sommet à genève l
entretien entre les présidents baden
poutine le président américain
a exprimé son intérêt de d'utiliser les
leviers américain pour assurer le
respect des accords de minsk il a émis
ce point qui
comprend la nécessité du statut spécial
ne l'avons soutenu c'était la même
histoire lors de l'entretien avec et
victoria nuland le secrétaire d'état
américain ensuite dont frites s'est
rendu en russie pour discuter
le dossier iranien
et ils ont tous confirmé la nécessité de
respecter les accords du nysc et serait
lé statut spécial à la marge de la ssii
le secrétaire d'état est honni blinken
l'a confirmé lui aussi
si les états unis comprennent la
nécessité de mettre la fin c'est
tentative de torpiller les accords de
misc de la part des autorités
ukrainiennes
on peut espérer que cela va aboutir
on voit des tentatives
de faire de spéculer
sur
la situation probablement sur un short
des changes on peut respecter les
accords de mise qu'ensuite on peut
sacrer sur la mesure de restriction dans
le contexte et des initiatives
présentées par la russie relatives aux
garanties de sécurité notamment les
garanties de non expression de l'otan à
l'est et l'exclusion de tout déploiement
des armes qui nous menace ray sur les
territoires des pays voisins
sur le territoire où ils peuvent
présenter la menace a l'air aussi je ne
vais pas vous donner des commenté à ce
sujet la seule chose que je pouvais dire
c'est que pour nous les deux choses sont
importantes le respect complet des
accords de minsk y compris
l'obligation ukrainienne d'assurer les
droits des minorités ce qui est écrit
dans la constitution ukrainienne et les
conventions européen
ou le crâne ou le crâne et nos membres
mais aussi des garanties plus large ce
qui concerne la prévisibilité des
relations entre la russie et le temps
s'il permettait une question
supplémentaire
est ce que vous envisagez quand même la
variante de l'escala de la situation
le conflit militaire et dans ce cas là
comment votre ministère va t'il région
vous savez
notre philosophie est connu
il s'agit de la chanson russe très
célèbre est ce que les russes veulent
faire de la guerre
nous n'en avons pas besoin nous ne
voulons pas d'avoir des conflits et nous
espérons que les autres ne les veulent
pas que les conflits ce n'est pas
quelque chose de désirable pour les
autres nous
nous allons assurer de manière très
ferme notre sécurité par les moyens que
nous considérons comme utiles
et nous prévenons
tous ceux qui pensent autre chose en
ukraine même à l'occident il y a des
des politiques et qu'ils essaient
d'alimenter ses humeurs agressive en
ukraine plus il y a
d'éléments agresseurs en nos frontières
plus il espère
nous faire sortir de nos gonds
poutine a déclaré hier alors du collège
du ministère de la défense nous avons
tous les moyens possibles pour assurer
la réponse militaire militaire et
technique à toutes les provocations et
qui vit surgir encore une fois et je
tiens à le souligner
de boer d'eric voudrions pas choisir ce
chemin le chemin de la confrontation
n'est le choix
c'est c'est notre collègue qui doit
faire le choix
nos collègues américains ont très vite
adopté le cadre avec nous alors cela
témoigne du fait que
c'est un pas positif malgré le fait
qu'il y aura bien sûr en volume énorme
de travail à faire c'est ton très bon
pas à la veille du nouvel an romane
diskin peut-il vous plaît vous avez
mentionné le changement de la position
allemande à propos des décors de minsk
ces dernières années malheureusement on
voit que les relations entre la russie
et l'allemagne se dégrade berlin
officielle en accuse la russie dites
nous quelle est l'origine quelles sont
les raisons 2 l'aggravation de la
détérioration des relations entre les
deux pays
vous savez j'ai déjà évoqué ce sujet
voilà ce que dit écouter ce que dit le
ministre de la défense de l'allemagne
ursula von der leyen quand elle a
travaillé au gouvernement de de
l'allemagne est ce qu'il dit maintenant
en tant que représentante de l'union
européenne ils disent la chose suivante
nous sommes intéressés à avoir des
relations normales avec la russie mais
au début la russie doit changer sa
conduite point
g a rencontré madame bareback à
stockholm
nous avons eu une bonne conversation
cette conversation a été brève pour les
raisons que vous comprenez j'ai confirmé
l'invitation pour elle de visiter moscou
elle envisage de le faire
j'ai prêté son attention au fait suivant
dans l'accord de coalition il y a le
tese de
de la diversité et de la profondeur des
relations entre la russie et l'allemagne
il ya la volonté de poursuivre un
dialogue constructif née en même temps
il y à d'autres approches envers les
relations avec la russie je ne veux pas
même les cités
des devises offensive par exemple
lorsque il ya une atteinte aux droits de
la société civile dans notre pays on
nous exige d'arrêter la déstabilisation
en ukraine nous en avons déjà parlé
il est évident ce sont les tendances de
la démocratie allemagne allemande il
faut coordonner
la composition de la coalition c'est la
vie
nous le prenons comme on fait donner
d'autant plus qu' il y a le parti social
démocratique et qui est à la tête du
gouvernement
et ce sont les leaders de ce parti qui
ont d'ailleurs assuré les périodes les
plus productives dans une relation
mutuellement bénéfique
et nous espérons
que les partenaires de ce parti dans
leur coalition
prêteront plus d'attention à ce que
comment ils comment nous pouvons établir
un agenda positif de nos relations
mais
la proche que quand par exemple une
partie une et riant à lui rapproché que
elle est impeccable et c'est la russie
qui doit changer sa conduite alors je me
sens tous adultes on ne comprenant que
on ne peut pas le faire
maxime altoria je tiens à lui de poser à
lui donner la parole merci beaucoup je
reviens en moyen orient
je voudrais parler de la syrie les
militaires leur présence de militaires
américains à leur présence reste
toujours une menace à l'intégrité
territoriale du pays la russie a appelé
à plusieurs reprises de retirer ces
militaires mais il reste toujours
compensées vous est ce que ce problème
durera et qu'est-ce qui peut
exhorté les états unis à retirer ses
forces et quels sont leurs objectifs
véritable vous savez pour les objectifs
véritable on les complaintes bien les
américains ne les cache pas
quand ils ont pris sous leur contrôle
les hydrocarbures les gisements l'est
les rêves à sun l'euphrate
l'agriculture ils ont commencé à appuyer
les séparatistes kurdes d'ailleurs le
territoire sur lequel cela se passe elle
concerne les terrains
d'habitation traditionnel des tribus
arabes ce qui n'ajoute pas d'harmonie
dans cela et n'ajoute pas d'autorité aux
américains
quand ils envisagent de planifier leurs
actions sur le terrain il faut aussi
tenir compte du facteur turc les
relations entre les arabes et les kurdes
sommes
bien sûr
la situation est difficile et lié à la
position de la turquie
la turquie envisage les kurdes les
organismes kurdes qui sont les
partenaires des américains en tant que
les cellules du parti de travail de
kurdistan qui considère qu'on m'a parti
terroriste
les kurdes cette aile politique de
l'union démocratique le conseil
démocratique de la série ils doivent
se déterminer
vous vous souvenez du fait que en étape
de notre âme pas dit que nous devons
partir de cela parce que nous n'avons
rien à voir en syrie et tout de suite
les kurdes ont demandé et nous on
demandait même d'instaurer dès lors de
les aider à la restaurer le dialogue
avec damas
quelques jours plus tard les
déclarations de john trap entêté de
désavouer le pentagone a dit qu'il
n'envisageait pas de partir les kurdes
en tout de suite perdu leur volonté
d'avoir un dialogue avec les autorités
de la syrie donc il faut le comprendre
le prendre en considération il ya
beaucoup plus de problèmes pour par
exemple le camp
le camp des réfugiés la zone 2
555 km d'altorf
ils n'arrivent pas à assurer la vie de
leur structure parmi les réfugiés il y à
beaucoup des terroristes et des bandits
moi je suis sur les kurdes doivent
prendre une position de principe nous
pouvons les aider d'ailleurs ils ne
rendent visite madame arquette nous a
rendu visite récemment et représentait
le conseil démocratique de la syrie et
nous expliquons à nos amis turcs que
nous ne voulons pas alimenter des
tendances négatives bien au contraire
notre tâche c'est
d'assurer le respect de la souveraineté
et de l'intégrité territoriale de la
syrie
et bien sûr il faut prendre en compte
les intérêts des minorités nationales
c'est l'une des conditions clés je pense
que les américaines le comprennent
qu'ils ne se sentent pas à l'aise là bas
mais pour l'instant il y reste et nous
continuons le dialogue entre les
militaires ce dialogue est assez
efficace il vise à prévenir des
incidents imprévus il ya aussi des
consultations du caractère assez
fiable en ce qui concerne l'application
de la résolution du conseil de sécurité
de l'onu nous sommes déjà depuis une
heure en ligne
la diffusion continue en langue
étrangère nous avons encore le temps
pour deux questions je vous demande mes
chers collègues de vous décidez vous
mêmes à qui vous donnera la parole
oui encore quelques questions madame
zakharova
l'aide du président des états unis de la
sécurité nationale at on fait une
déclaration franches il a dit que les
états unis aient essayé de manière très
active de transformer l'ordre du monde
existant à grâce à la formation de
nouveaux alliance de nouveaux
partenaires et 2 et des institutions qui
doit retravailler aux intérêts dus à
celle de washington
est ce que
c'est une menace sérieuse pour la russie
pour son influence et quels sont les cas
concrets que qu'entreprennent les
diplomats russe et les autorités russes
pour pour prévenir
l'effondrement ou le changement de la
fixité des structures de l'onu vous
savez ce sujet
nous date pas d'aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs j'ai mentionné déjà au début
de notre conversation que les états unis
et leurs alliés ont tu arrêter
d'utiliser le terme a le droit
international mais il parle de
l'application pour tout le monde de
respecter les règles de l'ordre qui est
basé sur les règles
c'est la même chose
dans le système de l'onu il ya beaucoup
de fonds de programmes des gens ce
spécial
des commissions régionales économique et
tous les pays ils sont représentés ces
pays sont ouverts ces organisations sont
ouverts à la participation d'autres pays
mais en même temps
on crée on continue à créer des
plateformes des appels hors des cadres
de l'onu par exemple
à paris il ya le forum de paix et dans
le cadre de ce forum ils ont déclaré la
création d'une plate-forme de la défense
de la liberté des journalistes des mass
media il y à beaucoup d'autres
initiatives par exemple dans la
cybersécurité
la protection du droit humanitaire
nationale pour toutes ces questions il y
a par exemple l'unesco le conseil des
droits de l'homme ou une autre structure
ou encore une fois je tiens à le
souligner sur la base universel tous les
règles ont été agréés
la charte de l'onu c'est aussi la règle
ne sont pas contre ces règles mais ce
sont les règles qui sont soutenus par
tout le monde
non collègues
par exemple dans le volet de la liberté
de la presse la situation en cyber
espace il voit ici la menace pour leurs
intérêts
ce que si on utilise la plateforme de
l'onu
pour agréer les règles acceptables pour
tout le monde
cela va nuire à leurs intérêts et qu'il
qui le veulent rendre
préférentielles dans tel ou tel domaine
des activités humaines
alors oui
ils veulent utiliser cette plateforme
pour élaborer leur propre les règles et
que sur cette plateforme os à
représenter non seulement le
gouvernement mais aussi le business la
société civile et ainsi ils le rendent
flou le caractère intergouvernemental
des accords qui ne peuvent qu'être très
fiable durable c'est leur politique
c'est le cap qui le promeuvent
nous pensons que c'est une
interprétation
non correct de ce dont nous avons besoin
pour les relations internationales
mon collègue secrétaire d'état monsieur
dean cain avec les rues hier que les
etats-unis ne pouvaient pas de jouer le
rôle leader dans le monde contemporain
et qu'il ne pouvait ne pas déterminer
les règles dans ce monde
nombreux sont ses
partenaires partout dans le monde qui
expriment leur joie que il dirige le
monde qu'il commande donnent leur temps
tone ans c'était on peut ainsi sa
déclaration
ils disent que il ya quelqu'un qui doit
être leader et sinon il y as en chaos
oui ça pourrait paraître réaliste mais
quand même il faut dépasser les
tendances de retour à easy money et le
président poutine a proposé d'ailleurs
d'organiser le sommet des membres
permanents du conseil de sécurité non
pas parce que ils sont plus
plus important que les autres mais il
représentait cet organe et il propose
d'agréer les idées communes comment il
faut renforcer le monde international la
sécurité je pense que ces
recommandations pourraient être écouté
avec attention par d'autres membres de
la communauté internationale nous allons
promouvoir cette idée nous travaillons
là dessus et nous discutons maintenant
des paramètres concrets la phase de
préparation
et bien sûr nous utiliserons cela pour
défendre
le droit international et dans la zone
isation auquel participe la russie par
exemple le est nu si que la cia brique
au cs
et le grupo des vins
le groupe d'evans c'est une image si
vous vous concentrez
de tout le spectre
des pays membres de l'onu
il ya les sept pays leader de l'occident
il ya des pays du brics et leurs
partisans
c'est la plateforme où on peut il faut
élaborer des déclaré des recommandations
qui seront ensuite apporté au format
plus universel comme par exemple
l'organisation des nations unies
la toute dernière question s'il vous
plaît
ce qui concerne à la ferme h 17 la cour
de la haye
n'a pas permis de déclasser les
témoignages s est 45 ainsi que
le procès verbal
qui prévoit que la mise le missile qui
avait frappé le boom
malaisien n'a pas été lancée de
l'endroit indiqué d'un l'enquète mais de
l'autre rencontre de l'autre endroit
quelle serait la réaction de la russie
où la décision finale sera prise
une fois la décision est prise et
publiés
je crois que nous allons présenter notre
opinion aussi mais pour l'instant nous
suivons attentivement les événements
avant tout parce que il s'agit des
citoyens des citoyens russes qui sont
les accusés à cette étape
pour nous il ya des tentatives de
créer l'image que cette affaire ne soit
pas pénal mais plutôt une affaire
nationale parce que la russie aurait
dirigé les actions de ces personnes là
c'est inacceptable pour nous parce que
là bas il s'agit d'un procès pénal
et c'est comme ça que nous ne le
considérons
et les juristes comprennent cette
affaire a
dans ce contexte il ya pas mal du cas de
la violation du non respect du procès
judiciaire parce que toute la formation
tous les témoignages sont classifiés
même ceux que vous avez évoqué
probablement cela pourrait
donner de nouveaux faits à lenquête et
la demande
des
défenseurs
été
révoqué il faut pas le négliger aussi
de plus est il faut prendre en compte
les faits présentés par alma santé
quand il s'agit d'un missile
précis l'utilisation de ce missile n'est
pas justifiée notre ministère de la
défense premier document
qui confirme que le missile avait été
produit dans les années 80 et avait été
délivré en ukraine et y est resté
jusqu'au jusqu'à son utilisation
mais tout cela a été négligée je
voudrais attirer votre attention à
d'autres faits plutôt politique mais
néanmoins ce sont des faits
près fiable au moment où cette
catastrophe a eu lieu
les premiers à venir à l'endroit de la
catastrophe je parle des internationaux
c'était les malaisiens parce que c'était
lors leur avion à leur compagnie
aérienne et de côté avec les
milices qu'on appelle les séparatistes
et cetera ils ont trouvé les
enregistreurs à bord
et ont
transmis les données sans tenter de les
couches de les cacher ces
enregistrements avaient été transmises à
l'âne al'expertise mais on ne connaît
des résultats
même aujourd'hui jamais
les néerlandais sont venus beaucoup plus
tard mais il ya un aspect très
intéressant
le néerlandais les français et les os
crânien ont créé un groupe d' enquête
conjointe ou les maladies n'ont pas été
invités
les malaisiens avait été invité
uniquement cinq ans plus tard mais selon
toutes les règles de
l'icao
un pays propriétaire de l'avion doit
être engagée le premier le troisième
aspect qui est qui est négligée parce
qu'ils accusent les autorités russes
sous-entend que nous avons initié la
prise de la résolution au conseil de
sécurité qui auraient instruits et
l'organisation internationale de
l'aviation civile
mener une enquête non biaisée
et établir aider principe qui servent de
la base pour cette enquête de plus de ce
moment là cette organisation n'avait pas
été engagé à lenquête c'est ce groupe
d'un guide qui a usurpé
le contrôle de cette enquête ce n'est
qu'à la fin qu'ils avaient invité les la
malaisie la russie
après un expérimente et si tout
a produit les données les informations
de ces riders
qui non plus n'avait pas été acceptée
bien que
c'est fait soit des faits établis non
contestés
personnes en demande à l'ukraine n'ont
plus à déclasser ces données la cour
était satisfait par l'information que
les riders n'avait pas fonctionné
personne ne demande à le craignent de
présenter les communications entre les
opérateurs et l'avion m h 17 une
personne une jeune fille qui était parmi
les opérateurs a disparu donc vous voyez
il ya pas mal de questions personne ne
demande aux américains de présenter les
données des deux leur sac lité qui selon
me confirme la décision de l'enquète
les amériques on a uniquement
enregistrés dans les documents que ces
arguments américain existe et c'est tout
on peut continuer de cataloguer c'est
c'est
ces faits qui ne trouve rien en fait
de plus les membres les familles et des
victimes ont essayé d'ouvrir lé enquête
sur la fermeture de l'espace aérien par
l'ukraine
on dit que cela n'est pas relatif l
enquête mais revenons à notre réalité
on prend un dernier lors de la première
vague et de ces accusés accès des
accusations contre la russie
que nous
menons des exercices militaires sur
notre territoire à côté de la frontière
c'était pas des
actes militaires uniquement des
exercices mme donc les états unis du
façon en affiches officielles ont appelé
leurs compagnies aériennes
évitées cette partie lors de leur vol
donc pour eux pour les américains les
exercices étaient une était un prétexte
suffisant pour demander ce type
de clôture de l'espace aérien
mais c'était une histoire tout à fait
contraire vis-à-vis l'ukraine donc je
dirais que ces exemples de la politique
à double mesure pullulent dans cette
situation ce qui re
malheureusement existe très souvent dans
nos relations avec les occidentaux
merci beaucoup cher participants je
crois que c'était plutôt une sorte de
conférence de presse qu'une interview en
tout cas je le remercie beaucoup merci
quelle est la différence entre la
conférence de presse et l'interview
donc ici nous avons plusieurs rédactions
mais la même chaîne
merci encore informent sur la drogue
merci madame makarova
pour ses
résultats de l'année écoulée j'espère de
vous voir plusieurs fois dans l'année
prochaine merci encore une fois est bon
nouvèl hambourg noël à tous
merci